grüne liste bis nämlich die musste die
nacht von mittwoch auf donnerstag im
krankenhaus verbringen für
vorsorgeuntersuchungen wie das britische
königshaus mitteilte und zwar hier im
king edward der sechste krankenhaus in
london wo auch im februar ihr
verstorbener mann prinz philip fahren
behandelt worden war zuvor hatten die
ärzte der 95 jährigen monarchin eine
geplante reise nach nordirland
verboten zitat die königin hat
widerwillig den medizinischen rat
angenommen sich in den nächsten tagen
auszuruhen sie sei guter stimmung jedoch
etwas enttäuscht darüber dass sie ihre
reise nicht antreten können heißt es
weiter in einer knappen mitteilung aus
dem buckingham palace ja und zu den
hintergründen und folgen haben wir bild
adels experte alexander von schönburg
bei uns im studio schönen guten morgen
alexander wie viel sorgen dass wir uns
jetzt machen um die queen
erfahren habe
und bei bester dinge trinkt wieder tee
macht sogar macht sogar korrespondenz
wieder und man hat einige termine das
problem war dass das sie sich dass
jemand ist der von ihren ärzten
zurückgepfiffen werden muss und es traut
sich natürlich wenige wenige trauen sich
der clean anweisungen zu geben und sie
besteht darauf dass ihr kalender voll
ist sie ist seit ende oktober hat sie
ich habe das mal nachgezählt hatte sie
19 große
wichtige große auftritte und termine
werden dass gerade gesehen in dem
bildschirm lief lief die veranstaltung
von dienstagabend eine riesige wo bill
gates und lauter investoren aus aller
welt zusammen und 195 davon 93 also wie
gesagt sie hat sie hat sehr viele
termine in letzter zeit wahrgenommen und
anfang november geht es geht gleich
weiter es ist ja ein glas chor jetzt
dieses große dieses große climate summit
also die sie gegen dieser klimagipfel
politiker und wirtschaftler aller welt
zusammenkommen und sie muss aber sie
muss einfach ein gang runterschalten das
haben mir ihre ärzte gesagt das sagen
ihre ärzte ihr schon lange und dann sagt
sie meistens nein nein überhaupt nicht
sie haben sozusagen unter mir dass ich
sie lässt sich da nicht sie lästig und
da war hat ihr hausarzt hat sich wohl da
durchgesetzt und womöglich auch um ihr
selbst sozusagen ein bisschen respekt
einzuflößen jetzt fahren wir ins
krankenhaus und mache ein paar tests was
interessantes ist tatsächlich nacht im
krankenhaus geblieben als das hat mich
überrascht ich hätte gedacht sie werden
zum test zu test ins krankenhaus
gefahren und wird dann auch wieder
zurückgebracht und sie hat sie ist
allerdings dort geblieben jetzt hat man
mir erklärt aus praktischen gründen also
es war wohl es war wohl bis dahin schon
22 uhr abends und dann hat man gesagt
nein jetzt bleibt sie hier entfernt erst
am nächsten morgen nach wien satz
alexander muss sich doch vorstellen dass
sie auch ärzte im buckingham palast hat
die ganze zeit die immer ein auge auf
sie haben oder nicht nein ist es nicht
so es gibt ein hausarzt aber es ist
nicht so dass da das dass das so wie bei
ich weiß ich arabischen ölprinzen ist
das daher dass da ein und ständig
umgegangen das ist das ist nicht schön
sie hat ein leid das ist ja house doctor
der geburt aber nicht im haus aber er
sieht sie natürlich regelmäßig aber auch
ehrlich gesagt nur wenn es notwendig ist
und die königin ist beim eigentlich für
ihr altern in sehr guter gesundes
einzige problemen die sie immer wieder
hat es keine gelenkprobleme ich hab
manchmal
rücken ein bisschen schmerzen aber
ansonsten sehr doch jetzt erst mal eben
auch im gehstock benutzt aber sie ist im
grunde eigentlich wie ihr mann extrem
fit für alte man sieht
also die einzigen krankheiten die von
ihm bekannte im letzten jahren ist dass
sie eigentlich eine erkältung mal hier
und da hatte jemand hat mir gesagt ich
worte kann es so einer ist ja im februar
gestorbenen prinz philip nachdem sie so
viele jahrzehnte mit ihm zusammen war
dass sie das doch mehr mitgenommen hat
als es nach außen entschieden das ist
natürlich schwer jetzt von außen außen
zu sehen also sie ist ja jemand der sich
nach außen immer die perfekte fassade
ist immer perfekt und gerade nach diesem
tod habe ich viele erwartet dass sie so
ein bisschen wie queen victoria nur noch
in schwarz gehen wird und sich sehr weit
zurückziehen wird das gegenteil war der
fall sie ist nach kürzester zeit wieder
im bund bunten kleidern sage jetzt mal
übertrieben rum glauben haben darüber
gewundert und sie hat auch angefangen
schnell wieder zu scherzen sie hat sich
wie gesagt keine termine aus dem
kalender streichen lassen hat noch darum
gebeten ihr noch weitere termine
einzustellen also sie ist extrem b sie
ehrlich gesagt und das ist auch der
grund warum eben die ärzte gesagt haben
so jetzt jetzt jetzt stoppt und da ist
sie eben einen da ist ja eine sehr
schwierige patientin ich glaube als
hausarzt hat man ungern einen monarchen
als
als patienten weil es ihm sehr schwierig
ist
den anweisungen zum vor allem sie die
disziplin in person es gibt inzwischen
ein offizielles statement vom buckingham
palace das können wir uns auch mal
gemeinsam anschauen da wird dann noch
mal eben offiziell stellung genommen zu
dieser aufenthalt im krankenhaus
alex in der zwischenzeit vielleicht mal
die frage die sich natürlich automatisch
stellt 95 jahre ist sie alt jetzt also
dieser zwischenfall jemand ist gestorben
sollte es wirklich zum schlimmsten
kommen und sie auch sterben dann ist
mittlerweile eigentlich ganz klar wie es
dann weitergehen wird also die
thronfolge ist ja offiziell festgelegt
aber es wurde ja immer mal spekuliert ob
dann sozusagen charles verzichten würde
und man gleich weitergehen würde
zugenommen das ist ehrlich gesagt ein
reines medienthema
also wie wir medien können darüber
spekulieren gut wir leben in zeiten die
ungewöhnlichsten dinge passieren also
dass es zwei päpste gibt habe ich ist
auch ungewöhnlich das hat auch paar
jahrhundert nämlich gegeben aber aber
die königin von england ist
erstmals spekulation würde sie zum
beispiel aus altersgründen zurücktreten
würde er würde sie nie machen das war
sie ist nach ihrem bewusstsein ist sie
gesalbte königin des landes und muss und
muss das bleiben bis zu ihrem letzten
atemzug
und diese und diese nachfolgediskussion
wie gesagt findet nur in den medien
statt innerhalb des des palastes gibt es
gibt es diese gibt es diese diskussion
nicht und
ich glaube ehrlich gesagt auch dass das
für william ein ziemlicher
schock wäre also der mann der muss auch
erst in diese in diese in diese
situation hinein wachsen wird dann
prince of wales das ist noch mal eine
aufgabe mit sehr sehr viel mehr
pflichten als junger familienvater so
geben wir den geben den jungen noch paar
jahre und umbauen bei charles ich würde
mal sagen es gibt auf der ganzen welt
kein besser ausgebildeten
könig oder dann ton hat ja lange geübt
hatte er kennt erkennt den laden erkennt
er kennt die pflichten also neben das
jetzt dem das jetzt streitig zu machen
wie halte ich für absurd
[Musik]